ask a leader a question that matters to
you at the annual meeting in Davos every
year the World Economic Forum sets up a
video booth and invites presidents
dignitaries and leaders to stop by and
respond to your questions about the
world's most pressing challenges so what
do you want to ask the world leaders in
Davos pose your question in video or
text and submit at youtube.com slash
Davos want to know who will be there
check out our list of participants wef
CH / participants or the official
Twitter list w EF c 8 / tweets will put
the top voted questions to the world
leaders at davos when they come to the
YouTube booth giving you direct access
to some of the most powerful and
influential people in the world go to
youtube.com slash divorced today and ask
a leader